vamos a aprender un poquito acerca de
cómo funciona un banco así normalito y
sencillito supongamos que yo soy un
emprendedor e identificó el siguiente
problema en el mundo hay un montón de
gente bien trabajadora que son pues no
sé doctores abogados constructores lo
que sea cualquier cosa que ellos hagan
funciona de la siguiente manera proveen
bienes o servicios y eso hace que puedan
acumular ahorros por el momento ese
entre comillas dinero esos ahorros
deciden guardarlos no sé enterrándolos
en el jardín a ahorros va entonces
simplemente está ahí está acumulándose
estos ahorros no están haciendo nada y
para entender un poco más los
trabajadores dieron bienes o servicios
las otras personas le dieron un algo que
no se puede ser oro o un pedazo de papel
que esencialmente dice este pedazo de
oro o este pedazo de papel te da derecho
a tener pues servicios en el futuro
entonces estas personas dicen sabes que
esto está súper útil déjame meterlo al
colchón bueno lo que sea entonces tienen
estos ahorros y además de esto va a ver
otro grupo de emprendedores
y lo que pasa con estos emprendedores es
que tienen un montón de buenas ideas
para proyectos dicen sabes que si
pudiera déjame escribirle por aquí
proyectos o inversiones proyectos
inversiones
inversiones entonces supongamos que hay
algún empresario de aquí que dice lo
siguiente oye sabes que la verdad yo no
tengo ni bienes ni recursos pero tengo
una idea así súper buena si pudiera
lograr que un montón de personas pues
quedaran canales hacia el hacia cierto
planteo entonces podría generar un mejor
plan tío todos tendríamos este más más
comida y eso de ahí sería un muy buen
servicio para la comunidad pero pues
como lo voy a hacer para lograr que
algunas personas construyan estos
canales
no sé a lo mejor puede prometerles que
en el futuro pues podría darle a ellos
más comida o lo que sea pero así no
funcionan las cosas nadie va a trabajar
para mí a menos que estén seguros de que
van a obtener algo de regreso entonces
aquí tenemos un problema interesante
tenemos un montón de personas que ya
dieron bienes y servicios al mundo y
después el mundo les dio unas ciertas
chinches
o billetes vamos a decir que solo y
antes de seguir déjame contarte algo
casi todo el mundo habla del oro como si
fuera algo muy muy especial así como si
realmente representara riqueza mientras
que el dinero no lo representara pero en
realidad el oro pues pues el oro no es
tan útil más allá de él desde el hecho
de que es bonito de hecho es muy bonito
es algo padre del oro es bonito y es
difícil de falsificar el dinero el
dinero en papel pues tiene otras
ventajas es más ligero es más práctico y
la verdad últimamente se ha vuelto
difícil de falsificar bueno mi punto es
este que hay algunas personas que
piensan que el oro es mejor que el
dinero en papel pero pues yo creo que
hay más que decir al respecto no te
preocupes ya nos tocará hablar más de
esto cuando hablemos de que suba y que
baje la inflación ahí hablaremos de
ventajas y desventajas del oro bueno por
el momento vamos a suponer que en esta
civilización pues no se es civilización
antigua les encantan los metales
preciosos y entonces usan el oro como
dinero
ahora tenemos un montón de personas que
dieron bienes y servicios y obtuvieron
estas chinches que son monedas de oro y
estas monedas es la forma en la que la
sociedad le dice a las personas sabes
que si tienes esto le puedes dar este
dinero a alguien más y va a hacer algo
por ti ahora cuánto necesitas darle pues
quién sabe verdad va a depender de la
ley de la oferta y la demanda y lo que
sea después lo veremos ahora los de acá
de la izquierda dicen pay sabes que si
al menos yo pudiera tener una forma de
convencer a alguien de construir un
canal sería realmente benéfico para
todos entonces pues tendríamos un montón
de comida y lo que sea pero cómo le hago
para hacer esto bueno si yo tuviera oro
si yo tuviera cierta cierta cantidad de
dinero entonces podría lograr convencer
a ciertas personas de que construyan un
canal y ya que está hecho el canal pues
podría no sé tal vez rentar lo para que
lo usen y entonces que crecieran muchos
planteos y cobrar al respecto generar
una riqueza bueno como la hacemos para
conseguir ese oro pues a lo mejor
podríamos tomar prestado de los
ahorradores y a lo mejor no es tan
difícil pues lograr convencer a los
ahorradores si lográramos convencerlos
de prestarnos el dinero
lo podríamos utilizar podríamos usar ese
dinero para pagarle a las personas que
van a ponerse a construir el canal para
los plantíos construyen el canal se
renta se generan riquezas y las
compartimos con los que nos prestaron el
dinero pero pues osea realmente es muy
difícil así de la nada que las personas
con dinero evalúen los proyectos de las
personas emprendedoras y puede ser que
pues en realidad necesitas los ahorros
de una persona sino de miles puede ser
un proyecto muy grande ahora del mismo
modo pues también es difícil a bueno más
bien es difícil evaluarlo pero también
esto es difícil que evalúen quienes
tienen ahorros claro por ejemplo si yo
tuviera ahorros y los tuviera guardados
en un colchón pues no me gustaría que
fuera algo muy público o sea si alguien
se entera de eso podría venir y robarme
lo entonces pues yo ahora si yo yo soy
un tercer emprendedor y veo esta
oportunidad de negocio un banco y qué es
lo que va a ser un banco vamos a hablar
de esto este de esta perspectiva bueno
para empezar yo soy un emprendedor y
necesito dinero para empezar este este
negocio
vamos a suponer que tengo algunos
ahorros para no pedirles a los que ya
los tienen y supongamos que empiezo con
un millón de monedas de oro vamos a
ponerle por aquí déjame dibujar mi hoja
de balance entonces digamos
esto de aquí es la hoja de balance como
puedes ver la hoja de balance era útil
incluso en las épocas primitivas verdad
esta de aquí es mi hoja de balance y
supongamos que inicialmente no sabes que
mejor lo voy a dibujar voy a dibujar mi
hoja de balance inicial aquí y vamos a
suponer que inicialmente pongo un millón
si creo que esta a ver que pongo un
millón de pesos
un millón de pesos
entonces si un millón de monedas bueno
vamos a decirle un millón de pesos un
millón de pesos porque ya estamos
acostumbrados a eso podemos decir que un
peso es una moneda de oro claro en la
actualidad ya no es así pero bueno te
vamos a decir que en esta aldea es así y
vamos a usar eso para construir una
estructura así bien grande de piedra
sólida que se ve muy muy segura este
entonces lo que voy a hacer es construir
una gran gran bóveda una bóveda así
enorme una bóveda así esto de aquí es el
capital que uso para construir así un
edificio súper sofisticado y que se ve
bien padre déjame dibujarlo tiene
algunos pilares por aquí y se ve como
algo se ve como un templo así griego o
romano antiguo y no es un look
accidental de hecho es para que se vea
muy muy resistente y pues es para que la
gente que confíe en dejar su dinero ahí
y pues que realmente sea seguro para que
la gente deje su dinero ahí va entonces
ya que construye este edificio te digo y
sabes que en vez de tener tu dinero
enterrado
jardín porque no viene si pones tu
dinero en este edificio de aquí cuando
quieras puedes venir y pues recuperarlo
y más aún te voy a pagar por tener el
dinero ahí y pues las personas dicen
bajen eso suena bien sales confiable y
bueno más que sal sea confiable
este edificio de aquí que se ve como un
gran templo se ve muy seguro entonces
todos estos todos los que ya trabajaron
me dan sus ahorros supongamos que eso es
pues que en total son pues 10 millones
de pesos de ahorros en esta en esta
aldea es una aldea bien bien rica bueno
ahora tengo 10 millones en depósitos
pero estos 10 millones son un pasivo
para mí este dinero no es mío me lo
dieron otras personas para que se los
guardará entonces es un pasivo esto de
aquí es un pasivo pasivo esto de aquí es
mi capital si en vez de solo ser yo
fuéramos 10 accionistas cada quien
tendría una décima parte pero ahorita yo
soy el dueño único y pues son todos míos
esto de aquí es el edificio recordemos
que esto no es una beneficiencia sino un
negocio entonces la pregunta natural es
de qué se trata el negocio que voy
con los 10 millones bueno ya le dije a
las personas que lo pueden obtener
cuando ellos quieran
ahorita se los estoy guardando y así con
mucha seguridad si vienen y lo intentan
pedir y no se los voy va a ser muy
sospechoso de modo que tengo que agarrar
tantito de este dinero y apartarlo
supongamos que hay tres mil o cuatro mil
personas y con pues con un poco de
suerte no todos van a venir y pedir todo
su dinero de este modo lo que voy a
hacer es que para cuando vengan las
poquitas personas voy a poner un poquito
de reserva digamos que voy a agarrar que
voy a agarrar el 10% de este dinero para
tenerlo en efectivo entonces el 10% lo
voy a poner en efectivo entonces me voy
a quedar con un millón de pesos y
después me quedan 9 millones extra con
un poco de suerte voy a poder ponerlos
para que hagan algo verdad con estos
nueve millones voy a hacer lo siguiente
los voy a prestar a las personas que
tienen muy buenos proyectos e
inversiones esto de aquí es un activo
verdad estos nueve millones son un
activo ahí va otra vez lo que estoy
haciendo es pido diez de esos diez uno
lo pongo aparte en efectivo los nueve
millones restantes los pongo en
varios proyectos en muchos muchos
proyectos no sean o no estoy dando nueve
millones a sólo una persona en realidad
estoy diversificando mis inversiones en
un montón de proyectos
la pregunta natural es en dónde está el
negocio pues bueno estos préstamos con
un poco de suerte los puse a trabajar en
canales o en fábricas algo que realmente
sea un proyecto que genere más valor del
que necesito para empezar con esto puedo
cargar un cierto interés ese interés
ahí está el negocio eso es lo que voy a
ganar supongamos que cargo 10 por ciento
de interés si y 10 por ciento de interés
ahora supongamos así nada más como para
no preocuparnos mucho que invertimos a
100 inversiones bien buenas somos el
primer banco y entonces todos nos sale
bien y nadie nos queda debiendo ahora no
todo este dinero es para mí recordemos
que las personas que dejaron su dinero a
guardar también les prometimos un
interés entonces hay que pagarles pues
digamos un 5 por ciento les voy a pagar
un 5 por ciento cuánto dinero ganó al
año pues de este lado de los 9 millones
estoy ganando el 10 por ciento entonces
estoy ganando 900
dos mil pesos al año 900 mil pesos al
año que están entrando a mi negocio y
cuánto sale pues 5 por ciento de 10
millones es 500.000 atrás entonces a ver
tenemos un ingreso de 900 mil salen 500
mil eso me deja con 400 mil supongamos
que además pues tengo que pagar pues
sueldos y seguridad de 100 mil con esto
lo que estoy haciendo es que que cada
año tenga 300 mil pesos de ganancias
bueno estas cuentas las voy a hacer con
más detalle en el siguiente vídeo pero
veamos la idea así desde arriba a
grandes rasgos estoy ganando 300 mil
pesos al año
con esto que consiste en emparejar a los
inversionistas con los de las ideas la
aldea tiene buenos proyectos para
desarrollarse los de las ideas hacen
realidad sus proyectos y los de los
ahorros pues tienen en donde guardar sus
ahorros y su dinero de hecho está
creciendo participando en esta inversión
en capital todo mundo gana bueno nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo